Adam it's lovely to have you here at
collector mania today what you're
enjoying about the event so far oh it's
just so nice going to these events and
kind of seeing everyone you forget know
how important the movies are you know
you do them and then you it's well you
know it's more than a job but when you
come here you realize how important it
is to people so it's so nice yeah and of
course it's a massive job as well isn't
it the amount of work that goes into
creating something like a trilogy like
the hobbits it's incredible I mean you
went to dwarf boot camp for example
didn't you tell us about that I did yes
I did God must have been to two month
almost two months of horse training
stunt training dialect lessons singing
lessons yeah all of that horse riding
bonding with the other dwarves and it
was kind of a I think a really clever
way from as well although it was really
useful it was a way of us bonding as a
kind of group of actors which was good
and kind of look yeah we kind of just
went on the journey like like the
dwarves did I guess what was the
toughest thing you had to do during that
boot camp oh god listen I never went to
the gym before this job so I think going
to the gym was on a regular occurrence
was that was pretty pretty tough for me
I had no idea what it was to be sweaty
before the hole is but now now I know
what the gyms like and I'm a regular not
not that much of a regular burglar but
more than ever yeah now you mentioned
being hot there I guess it was quite hot
in those costumes as well wasn't it
filming well incredibly hot yeah we are
we had these cooling vests underneath
our fat suits which after every take we
were plugged in we had a hose attached
coming out of our costume and they would
hold water right round our bodies
instantly freezing us so yeah that was
we were looks after but it was bloody
hot yeah who did you get to know best
when you're working on thurs I could
trust you i got to know pretty much
everyone very well ok we divorce became
very very close so many good friends all
of all of the boys all of the boys
martin freeman ian mckellen and jimmy
Nesbitt as well as you know my Kiwi
friends mark Hadlow Jed Stephen Dean
yeah just constantly emailing each other
and sending photos so we haven't really
left each other always get all here what
do they want come on my phone every day
that the reason here I remember one Lord
of the Rings some of the guys got
together they were had tattoos didn't
they too kind of mark the occasion was
there anything that you did to mark the
occasion of the hobbits being there
together I think every weekend we marked
the occasion by going out and drinking
and pickling my liver but we didn't do
the tattoos that was the that was the
guys the other guys think we we actually
had rings made I don't have mine on
which is pretty bad but it's a
personalized ring and each dwarf has one
and inside is a personalized message so
yeah we had that and yeah but we didn't
did that we didn't do the tattoo thing
although some of that some of us wanted
to and something lasting you were
forgetting a tattoo
ah yeah I would have done it yeah I
don't know where I put it haha I'm sure
I would have done it my ass or something
what would you got done doing when you
had a morir space corner absolutely not
no I know you mentioned earlier about
the boot camp and learning to sing the
singing lessons as well how did you find
that because obviously the singing was
going important part of the dwarves lies
isn't it it was yeah I became incredibly
good at humming I wasn't the singer me
and dean ogorman were in the bat singing
humming sorry while we left out to mark
had noticing and he was a great singer
ya know we did a lot and it was a good
way of us kind of kind of finary special
moments in the first movie actually
singing bit and learning dwarvish you
mentioned as well how did you find that
and can you remember any now no so
you're gonna have to ask william kircher
because his characters beats constantly
in elvish but ya know we did remember it
and you'll have to buy the extended
edition because it tells you all about
it
is that tough though having to learn
saying like that even if you're not like
like William was having to use it all
the time yeah it was tough it's a week
and the language to get your head around
actually there's no logic to at all yeah
so that so yeah that's pretty tricky
also what was it like working with Peter
Jackson wow it's just he's just a lovely
lovely man so to be spending two and a
half years with really and it didn't
feel like you would do one of the
biggest movies ever just felt like you
were working on a really special
projects in his kind of oversized garage
in New Zealand it's probably not the
case it were it definitely had the
budget behind ear but it it felt very
comfortable and very normal there it's
quite a commitment I suppose as an actor
I mean such a long period of time to
commit to a big project like that going
all the way to the side of the world as
well and what did you feel like when you
got the phone call ah oh I didn't
believe at all
I was on the North Circular and I
stopped the car and went to the pub and
had a scotch and I never drink scotch
and then I was running around the pub
asking for a phone charger so I could
put my parents and my friends to tell
them the news so yeah it was just
incredible yeah what's the best part of
playing already do you think I love the
fact that he's a complete fish out of
water he's he shouldn't really be on
this journey but somehow he's got
courage in his heart that kind of wants
to carry on and be one of the boys and I
think he kind of proves himself of the
three movies so yeah I love it mr. it's
kind of a little tear away really
you